pourquoi est ce que les vidéos qui
viennent d'être postée sur youtube ce
bloc à 300 une vue pendant une journée
hier je suis tombé sur une vidéo en
anglais d'un mec qui a posé la question
au chef de produit du service analytique
de youtube qui explique tout et comme je
sais que ça peut intéresser ceux qui
regardent pas mal de vidéos sur youtube
ou même ceux qui postent des vidéos sur
youtube alors à fait combien tu as vu de
pire 300 une vue 300 une vue 320
enfin ça ça bloque un seppois sur le
poste de fou malade j'ai décidé de vous
résumer cette explication comme ça tout
le monde saura 1 il ya plus de excusez
moi je ne savais pas je n'avais pas
compris la vidéo je parle pas anglais
désolé je suis désolé vraiment il faut
savoir que lorsqu'une vidéo est postée
sur youtube en fait cette vidéo est
dupliquée sur différents serveurs au
tour du monde comme ça si vous regardez
cette vidéo par exemple depuis paris eh
bien vous regardez une vidéo qui
présente sur des serveurs en france ou
en europe 1 pas besoin d'aller à
chercher aux etats-unis au japon et
ensuite les serveurs présents un petit
peu partout sur la planète envoient
l'information à youtube
ils me disent voilà cette vidéo a été
vue une fois sur mes serveurs vas-y amis
youtube tu notes aller l'autre chose à
savoir est que youtube différencie deux
types de vidéos celles qui font 300 vues
ou moins et celles qui font plus de 300
vues donc si une vidéo fait dit vu 20 30
cents 200 jusqu'à 300 youtube laisse le
compteur augmenté normalement et si une
vidéo fait plus de 300 vues alors
youtube estime qu'il faut vérifier les
vues alors le compteur ce bloc à 301 et
youtube vérifie s'il n'y a pas des
robots qui s'amusent à cliquer des
milliers de fois pour faire gonfler le
compteur c'est de la triche ville un
robot jeter à l'oeil
youtube enlève alors ces fausses vue et
après un peu moins d'une journée affiche
le vrai nombre au compteur et là vous me
dites oui mais
attend parfois le compteur ce bloc 1 300
de vue ou même plus
et en plus d'avoir la même voie que le
grand père dans les simpson vous avez
raison
l'explication la voici au moment de
dépasser les 300 vue c'est à dire de
passer d'une vidéo youtube ne vérifient
pas les vues à une vidéo où ils
vérifient il se peut que youtube
comptabilise plusieurs vues qui arrivent
en même temps de différents serveurs et
comme elles sont arrivées en même temps
youtube les additionne avant de bloquer
le compteur pendant une journée ce qui
fait qu'on peut voir des nombres allant
jusqu'à 320 comme 300 2 303 fin vous les
connaissez les chiffres entre 300 et 320
normalement si vous êtes allé à l'école
maintenant dès que vous verrez quelqu'un
poster un commentaire du genre si toi
aussi tu le 301e pouces verts ou alors
300 une vue et 1340 de commentaire wtf
montrez-lui cette vidéo si votre devoir
civique
merci à nos martyrs ou number five c'est
pas comme il faut dire pour sa vidéo
d'explication c'est une chaîne youtube
qui parlent de chiffres
grosse grosse ambiance dans la vie du
mec des chiffres et je vous dis à très
vite
[Musique]